et qu'auraient été les Beatles
sans George Martin
aussi
alors maintenant oh
tu récites toujours la Saint-Valentin pour
l'anniversaire de Dubaï ouais tu l'as fait J'ai eu un
très beau message de Paul ouais quand
j'avais 64 ans. ouais une bouteille de vin et un
anniversaire  salut ici j'ai été obligé de
te dire que tu sais euh tu es connu dans le
monde entier et pour toujours en tant que
producteur des Beatles mais très peu de gens
savent qu'en 69 tu as commencé un studio à
Londres appelé air studio et 10 ans
plus tard un autre studio à Montserrat dans
le  Caraïbes appelé eStudio monstre
belle île assez petite très près de l'
une de vos îles c'était à
Guadalupe
euh c'est très montagneux
et il pleut beaucoup mais principalement la
nuit de septembre le 17
septembre 89 il y a eu un ouragan
dans les Caraïbes et  12 000 personnes ont
tout perdu dans l'île non c'était une
dévastation complète ouais j'y suis allé
dès que j'ai pu ouais parce que pendant la
première semaine nous n'avons même pas pu parler à
personne ouais parce que l'ouragan
a rendu tout le monde sans abri le port a été
détruit l'hôpital avait  a perdu la moitié de
ses quartiers
et même la génération de toute l'électricité
est allée à toute l'île pas d'électricité
nous n'avions pas d'électricité pendant deux
mois
tout était un mandat Studio a été
hors d'usage de savoir que notre studio n'a pas
fonctionné depuis lors parce que
bien que  le studio lui-même était bien
construit ouais néanmoins nous n'avions pas d'électricité
pas de climatisation et l'île
n'était pas en état d'avoir des
stars célèbres là-bas ouais tu sais si Mick
Jagger y va il veut un peu
de confort ouais et il y a  pas de confort
là-bas en ce moment, alors vous avez décidé de collecter des
fonds et vous avez décidé de vendre un
disque un album et vous demandez des numéros à
différentes stars
bien sûr
Simply Red
Medio the Rolling Stone vous a donné
quelque chose de spécial maintenant alors ils m'ont donné
l'une des pistes qu'ils  n'avaient pas en fait
sorti tout seuls ce qui était très gentil
de leur part parce qu'ils avaient fait leur album
l'année dernière ouais pas très longtemps avant l'
ouragan à montserrand et quand j'ai
entendu parler de la catastrophe j'ai dit eh bien je suis
sûr que tout le monde veut aider les gens
de l'île a tout perdu
et j'ai contacté chaque artiste et tout le
monde a dit bien sûr que nous donnerons
une piste donc sur le disque est une piste
que chaque artiste a faite sur l'
île ouais Dire Straits j'ai besoin de toi Boy
George Duran Statut de Duran  quo
alors parlons de ta vie maintenant que
faisais-tu avant de rencontrer
les Beatles ou les Beatles te rencontraient
bien je suis producteur de disques depuis
12 ans déjà mais je dirigeais le
label parlophone ouais en Angleterre ouais
et un petit label  donc j'ai tout fait
et c'était une branche d'imai une branche d'
Emi un tout petit label anglais et je
devais tout enregistrer du jazz
musique classique musique populaire tout
et j'ai décidé de me spécialiser dans les disques de comédie
et je l'ai fait en fait pour commencer  J'étais
connu en tant que producteur de comédie, c'est
pourquoi vous vous en souvenez Peter Sellers ou Peter
juste assez
euh et je me suis fait une réputation pour ça et
en fait quand les Beatles sont arrivés ouais
c'était l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous nous
entendions trop bien parce
que  eux j'étais célèbre parce que j'ai fait tous
ces disques qu'ils aimaient
et ils pensaient qu'ils s'amuseraient
peut-être pas bien avec toi et ils avaient aussi
le même genre d'humour qu'eux ils
avaient ce type bizarre loufoque ouais j'aimerais
savoir  comment tu es entré en contact
avec eux la première fois que c'est par toi tu as
reçu un appel amusant d'un gars appelé
Sid Coleman à propos d'un autre gars appelé
Brian Epstein et tu as décidé de
les rencontrer ce qui s'est
bien passé Brian avait été dans toutes les
maisons de disques du  pays et je ne le savais pas
en fait si je l'avais su je ne suis pas
sûr que j'aurais pris mais de toute façon je
ne savais pas qu'ils ont été refusés par
Deca par Phillips tout le monde tout le monde
même même Emi ouais ouais et les deux de
les gens d'Emi avaient fait ça
euh bien apparemment, il est allé au
magasin d'Oxford Street pour faire
couper des disques à partir de bandes qu'il avait afin qu'il
puisse toujours essayer d'obtenir de l'action et
l'homme qui a écouté le disque et a
dit pourquoi n'a-t-il pas  vous ne les emmenez pas à la sitcom
et qui est un éditeur de musique
et donc il est allé à Seaside common et à la
sitcom et a dit à qui avez-vous montré ces
deux Brian a récité toutes les personnes qu'il a dites
eh bien c'est à peu près tout le monde qu'il a dit
avez-vous essayé George Martin
il a dit  non c'est George Martin
il a dit ben c'est un mec qui a la
réputation de faire des trucs insolites
et
sur palafa
j'étais le genre de Joker du jeu de
cartes tu comprends j'étais le fond
du parc
et il est venu me voir et  J'ai écouté ce
qu'il avait
quand avez-vous vraiment pensé que la première fois que
vous aviez son euh eh bien, c'étaient de très mauvais
disques ouais donc je me suis senti désolé pour les
gens plus tard qui les avaient refusés
mais il y avait quelque chose là-bas que je
trouvais intéressant et je
cherchais quelque chose de toute façon alors j'ai dit que je
ne peux pas juger là-dessus, je vais devoir
les voir et je vais devoir travailler avec eux
avant de pouvoir me décider et vous vous
lui demandez de les faire venir de Hambourg
où  ils jouaient dans le star club
célèbre star club à toi juste pour avoir une
audition dans un dans un Bay Road
on est venu à Abbey Road ouais et j'ai passé
une soirée avec eux ouais
et j'en suis tombé amoureux ouais
coup de foudre toi  dites l'amour au début ouais
et où ont-ils joué pour vous la
première fois eh
bien des chansons très ennuyeuses en fait
euh je pense bien qu'ils ont joué Love Me Do
ouais j'ai aussi joué des choses comme sur l'
arc-en-ciel ouais
ouais
et donc ils ne se sont pas montrés à ça  le temps
qu'ils pouvaient être de grands compositeurs
rien qu'ils n'aient écrit ouais c'était
très bien Love Me Do était à peu près le meilleur qu'ils
avaient ils avaient une version de s'il vous plaît
me plaire mais c'était très lent
à propos de Roy Orbison très très lent
et donc Love Me Do  J'ai choisi comme premier
tu dis que George était le plus
bavard après le premier enregistrement ouais
j'ai pensé bien peut-être que je n'obtiens pas
ce son comme ils pensent qu'il devrait
être alors je les ai amenés dans le contrôleur
j'ai dit regarde écoute  à cela et s'il
y a quelque chose que vous n'aimez pas, faites-le moi
savoir ouais et George George m'a dit et
a dit bien pour commencer je n'aime pas
votre
offre de temps mieux vous pensiez qu'il n'était pas un bon
bon batteur vous vouliez  en avoir un
autre et vous avez pensé à un gars pro
appelé Andy White et ils vous ont présenté ils
vous ont présenté Ringo Starr et
pourquoi avez-vous choisi l'étoile à la fin
au lieu de votre gars et le blanc bien je
n'ai pas le truc c'est que je '  d Je ne
voulais pas sauter de The Frying Pan Into
the Fire tu comprends ouais et je savais
que je devais avoir un meilleur drame que les
pieds donc Andy White était un habitué il était
un musicien de top session quand Ringo est
arrivé je n'ai pas  Je ne le connais pas du tout et j'ai donc
dit aux garçons, regardez, il est peut-être bon,
mais en ce qui me concerne, j'ai
ce gars pour lequel nous payons de l'argent,
utilisons-le, mais quand Ringo a commencé à
jouer, il avait  un son distinctif et et
il s'est très bien intégré mais il ne m'a jamais
pardonné de ne pas l'avoir laissé échouer cette
première session il m'en veut toujours
ouais le problème était de savoir
qui sera le leader du groupe
parce que vous ne saviez pas  parmi eux qui
sera le leader et vous avez décidé de
les voir jouer dans la caverne à
Liverpool oui bien sûr j'ai vu tout ce qu'ils faisaient dans
la cabine
n'oubliez pas à cette époque les groupes
qui existaient étaient concentrés autour d'une
personne comme Cliff Richard et  l'ombre
et c'était inhabituel d'avoir un groupe
démocrate si vous voulez ouais mais
quand j'étais à Liverpool, j'ai réalisé
que le groupe ne devait pas être changé, ils
étaient morts tels quels et il était
évident que celui qui a écrit le  la chanson la
chantait ils te proposaient des chansons
et chaque fois que tu disais que je veux plus
je veux plus et ils sont venus avec le de
moi à toi avec elle t'aime et tu as
dit qu'ils étaient sans fond de chansons
tu as découvert qu'ils étaient vraiment de grands
auteurs-compositeurs toi  savoir très rapidement le
succès en fait le succès les a aidés
ouais ça leur a fait réaliser qu'ils devaient
travailler plus dur et c'était comme mettre
une petite plante dans une serre et
allumer la lumière du soleil ils ont soudainement
fleuri et ils étaient merveilleux cette
première année fantastique tu es venu à Paris
avec  eux pour l'Olympia parce qu'ils
devaient enregistrer des chansons en allemand non je suis
allé à Old Iran et elle t'aimait en
allemand parce qu'imagine qu'il voulait qu'ils
chantent en allemand et quand tu es allé à Paris
tu as appris que le disque était
numéro un dans le  états
et tu es venu au Georgia Five il y
avait une fête bien c'était une période très excitante
tout d'abord les Beatles ne
voulaient pas enregistrer dans une langue étrangère
n'importe où ouais et ils pensaient que c'était
idiot ouais et ils avaient tout à fait raison
ouais en fait  mais les Allemands ont insisté pour que nous le fassions
et pour commencer ils ne
voulaient pas le faire ils se produisaient à l'
Olympia de Paris et quand le moment est venu
pour eux aussi de
faire cet enregistrement ils
ne se sont pas présentés et j'étais à  les studios
les attendaient
et j'ai continué à regarder autour de moi ce qui
s'était passé vous savez qu'ils ne sont pas venus j'ai
appelé le George a coulé j'ai parlé à Neil
aspenov qui était le directeur de la route Directeur de la route
et il a dit bien je suis désolé
George mais ils le feraient  dis qu'ils ne viennent pas
j'ai dit est-ce que tu vas leur dire que je les veux
ici en ce moment et je n'ai pas de
bêtises et
il a dit eh bien tu devras
leur dire toi-même je suis monté dans un taxi et je suis
retourné à  Azure disant que je suis monté dans leur
appartement à l'éclatement j'ai dit ce que
vous savez en quelque sorte leur crier dessus
et ils prenaient tous le thé autour de la
table avec Jane Nasha c'était la
petite amie de Paul elle était là en train de verser du thé et
c'était comme une scène  hors d'Alice au
pays des merveilles ouais
et dès que je suis entré dans la porte, ils ont
tous couru dans tous les coins de la
pièce et ont mis des coussins sur leurs têtes
et ici mec et ont prétendu qu'ils avaient
peur et que vous ne pouviez pas être en colère contre
eux du tout vous  sais qu'ils étaient si
charmants et ils sont venus dans les studios
et nous avons fait le travail oui mais ils avaient
tout à fait raison nous n'aurions pas dû le faire
vous étiez très impliqué et essentiel dans
la transition du rock and roll à la
musique pop à la musique pop progressive et  tu
leur as fait découvrir de nouveaux instruments pour
eux comme des instruments classiques par
exemple et on peut l'entendre sur Ilana
Rigby car quand tu enregistrais de la
musique classique tu étais spécialisé dans le
baroque non ils avaient une éternelle curiosité
ouais ils voulaient toujours en savoir plus
et ils étaient toujours  me disant
donnez-moi de nouvelles chansons qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est-ce qu'un
orchestre classique ouais et je
leur donnerais donnez-leur ce que je savais
ouais et quand il s'agissait de Penny Lane euh
Paul avait entendu un concerto de Bach Brandebourg
et il m'est venu ce qui suit
jours et j'ai entendu un son fantastique hier
soir c'était un morceau d'écorce j'ai dit la
trompette très haute oui vous pouvez y arriver il a
dit pouvions nous l'utiliser
d'
enregistrer comme une bande inversée sur
Tomorrow Never Never Knows No eh bien,
j'expérimentais toujours à l'époque
parce que nous n'avions pas de synthétiseurs, vous
savez qu'ils sont un produit d'aujourd'hui et si
nous devions faire des sons bizarres, nous devions
le faire nous-mêmes  et la seule façon de le faire
était de jouer comme tant de
gens l'ont fait depuis qu'ils ont leurs propres
enregistreurs et je ferais toutes sortes de
découpages des bandes et de les
remonter et John vous a dit à chaque
fois de vous en occuper parce que  Je ne
sais pas c'est pour Strawberry Fields Forever
il voulait garder la première partie de when
song et la deuxième partie de l'autre
prise disons que c'est vrai et il a dit
s'en occuper et toi tu l'as
pas bien géré le problème avec le  deux morceaux
qu'il voulait assembler étaient qu'ils
étaient dans des clés différentes ouais et dans des
pouces différents mais en faisant glisser les
vitesses autour, j'ai pu les
rassembler pour qu'ensuite quatre pistes
se produisent, vous savez ouais et vous avez
fait le sergent  Pepper avec seulement quatre
pistes c'est vrai comment tu as fait
pour faire
euh je n'aurais pas pu faire autrement
parce que c'est tout il y avait ouais tu
sais si j'avais eu 16 pistes ou 24 ou 48
pistes je les aurais utilisé  mais je
n'avais que du portrait donc c'est comme ça que j'ai fait c'est
pas si mal
et tu les as beaucoup aidés parce qu'ils
sont venus vers toi avec des embryons de chansons ou de
matière première et tu les a aidés à faire des
chansons définitives aussi ouais ben ça faisait
partie de la  cela faisait partie
du processus aujourd'hui d'être un bon
producteur pour être quelqu'un en qui les artistes
peuvent avoir confiance et
qui donnera une opinion vraie
parce que si vous êtes très célèbre et que vous
êtes un grand auteur-compositeur et que vous travaillez certainement
pour quelqu'un et  tu es très célèbre
ils diront que c'est fantastique ouais les gens ont
peur de dire je pense que ça peut être
mieux et c'est ce qu'un producteur doit
faire
comment avez-vous été payé avez-vous
reçu des frais ou des redevances comment êtes-vous payé
sur ces dossiers mal mal
non pour commencer j'étais un membre du personnel d'
EMR donc tout ce que j'ai obtenu était de 3 200 livres par an
pas beaucoup pas de voiture
pas de redevances ne
sait pas de commission  c'est vraiment pourquoi
je suis parti, je suis parti en 65 et j'ai créé ma propre
entreprise, puis j'ai touché des redevances et vous
avez eu des problèmes plus tard lorsque vous avez enregistré le
mécanisme dans mon vous savez
de quelle manière d'une manière qu'ils ont dit sur
votre contrat que vous devez enregistrer  Les
Beatles vous avez raison et vous avez dit la
scission mais ils disent non c'est donc ça
s'appelle makate c'est vrai parce que quand
nous avons négocié un accord pour
la loyauté des Beatles c'était une très petite somme c'était
vingt pour cent d'un penny ouais seulement une
très petite quantité ouais  et quand je suis venu
enregistrer McCartney, ils ont dit que vous aviez dit que
vous enregistreriez que vous aviez garanti d'
enregistrer les Beatles ouais et c'est le
même rythme mais euh je me suis disputé
comment avez-vous vécu les scissions
c'était une période difficile et parce qu'ils
étaient mécontents les uns des autres
et c'était le pire moment de tous
parce que je pensais vraiment que c'était
la fin de la route parce qu'ils
se disputaient tout le temps et que les femmes
ne s'aidaient pas
et j'étais assez surpris après ça
être quand Paul m'a appelé et a dit que nous
aimerions faire un autre disque avec vous
qui a été écrit par Abby
et j'ai dit eh bien je ne le ferai que si nous le faisons
comme nous l'avons fait auparavant avec une
production appropriée et il a dit que nous allons  fais ça
alors nous avons fini sur Abbey Road et
c'était très heureux que nous ayons tous bien fait
ensemble dire que deux c'est fantastique ouais le
côté deux de baby rub était ce que j'avais toujours
voulu faire après le poivre pour faire une sorte
de champ symphonique ouais
et John ne voulait pas faire ça John
voulait un disque de rock and roll donc quand nous avons
fait Abbey Road c'était un compromis d'un
côté c'était ce que je voulais faire avec
volonté John et l'autre c'était plus
toi et Paul Mindy comment avez-vous fait  tu as
appris la mort de John
euh où étais-tu j'étais chez moi et il
était tôt le matin
six heures du matin
et je devais aller au studio
car je travaillais avec Paul
McCartney sur le tir à la corde
et j'ai entendu la nouvelle et j'ai immédiatement
appelé Paul chez lui
j'ai dit je suppose que tu ne veux pas venir
aujourd'hui tu préfères ne pas travailler aujourd'hui
il a dit je ne peux pas rester ici je dois
entrer je  'ai une porte
alors nous avons convenu de nous rencontrer en studio et
nous n'avons fait aucun travail, nous avons juste parlé toute
la journée de John,
euh, nous avons
juste en quelque sorte réussi à le sortir de notre
système, c'était un choc terrible et cela a
aidé à pouvoir  se parler
des bons moments
c'était affreux
le seul
si je peux te reprocher quelque chose pourquoi as
tu accepté de réaliser la partition musicale
du film papier sergent produit par
Robert stickwood avec les Bee Gees et
Peter Frampton bonne question ouais euh
c'était  il avait toutes les références pour
être bon parce que c'était une pièce de théâtre
à euh à Broadway
qui était extrêmement bien mise en scène et un
vieil ami à moi appelé Jim Dale
qui est une star de Broadway maintenant
je l'ai vu et j'ai dit que c'était fantastique
et s'ils font un  film de ça ça va être
merveilleux
mais ce que je n'avais pas réalisé c'est qu'une fois que j'ai
tourné le contrat pour le faire j'étais
impliqué et je n'avais pas réalisé que toutes
les chansons qui m'étaient si chères
allaient être enregistrées  et j'ai dû
les enregistrer avec des gens que je ne connaissais pas
ouais euh tu sais c'était bouleversant
mais voilà c'est la vie tu prends
de bonnes décisions tu en prends de mauvaises
et est-ce que tu rencontres toujours George et
Ringo non parfois euh je n'ai pas  Je n'ai pas vu
Ringo depuis qu'il a eu sa petite houle en
ouais en Amérique et j'ai vu George
récemment ouais euh
prends ça je vais bien on parle encore
de temps en temps
mais je vois surtout du porno qu'est-ce que les
Beatles ont ajouté que d'autres n'ont pas fait  tes
yeux
c'était la chanson
c'était les chansons étaient des chansons brillantes
et elles avaient
un puits de créativité que je n'avais
expérimenté chez personne d'autre
elles étaient fantastiques
et ce qu'auraient été les Beatles
sans George Martin oh Les Beatles
auraient été les Beatles  Je suis sûr que je suis
sûr que quelqu'un aurait pris et fait que
ça n'aurait peut-être pas été pareil mais ça
aurait été ils étaient quand même trop
bons pour ne pas arriver et que serait-ce
George Martin sans les
Beatles qui font probablement encore de la comédie
petit-déjeuner